after being sworn in by king willem
alexander prime minister margaret starts
his fourth term in office rita is the
longest-serving european leader together
with victor orban from hungary and
nearly the longest-serving prime
minister in dutch history he have to
give us the feeling that
he is the old one but it is a new era
with new ideas
and with
maybe with with
with to try
to be again
connected with the people can you do
that
i don't know that's a big question
the netherlands has become increasingly
polarized since the start of the
pandemic with nearly weekly
anti-government protests dozens of
protesters held a rally during the
cabinet inauguration the first issue on
the agenda is to regain trust research
shows that trust in politics politicians
and state institutions has gone down
from 70 percent to 29 percent in the
past year the main question is now can
the same prime minister and the same
coalition parties win this back
after british government was forced to
resign early last year the new cabinet
looks very much the same as the old one
but instead of putting a cap on spending
this one aims to allocate billions of
dollars to climate policies and housing
and aims to be more pro-european many
dutch voters aren't impressed
i think it will be the same as last
so if if the prime minister stays it
stays the same
totally nothing i don't expect anything
at all it can't get any worse than it is
already the main frustration is the way
the government has handled the covet
pandemic compared to other european
nations the netherlands has strict
lockdown measures in place with public
places shops and restaurants closed due
to high infection rates and a late start
of the booster campaign what i
experience in the netherlands is a
political leadership that really follows
the trends in society rather than leads
it it seems that in the netherlands
looking at the polls and looking at the
sentiment in the in in the in the
population is more important
for your political decisions in the next
three weeks
than really having a vision and leading
the population to that vision while many
hope that this government will offer a
long-term vision to handle the pandemic
the current lockdown which is in place
until the end of this week will most
likely be extended step faster al
jazeera the hague